[Music]
in always a criminal news always a
criminal always a criminal submitted by
long live King Joe thank you very much
eternally a man who attacked cafe
workers turned out to be a murder
suspect who was just released from jail
oh damn he really sucks her staying on
below huh he's crazy
that means he's a threat to society
because all that right he just cannot
contain his violence yes no man is that
low self-control is really impulsive I
just saw a film with Vince Vaughn in it
where he's playing a serious role of
like some kind of like white like hitman
dude cause he's the one he beats the car
up that one yeah you punched the
windshield it's like it's kind of so
ridiculous how strong his characters in
that film
yeah but the fighting is brutal dude I'm
talking about like he smashed somebody's
face into the floor with the bottom his
foot scraped his face off the floor oh
[ __ ] that's tired I was like mortified
I think that's mean is that a good movie
it is I want to watch it in Vince Vaughn
by the way great actor oh that's cool
because I never see him in that kind of
role like to go into actor I think he's
so funny and I'm glad he's doing
something then yeah I never knew I would
have never known I was like dude he's a
[ __ ] amazing actor Wow so this dude
here his name is Carlton or was Carlton
oh that's why he's so violent he's
probably been made fun of all his life
Carlton banks Carlton banks he's black
Carlton banks miling yeah so he was 40
oh no dang I just had the number
fifty-four years old that phone looks
like he's unsure if you can see or not
they just got a really bad phone he's
blinking barn if I could see yet and I
can see what you get the agent used
because he doesn't look either one of
those agents he got some really [ __ ]
good skin he looks like a fat Carlton
yeah he does yeah Alphonso removing area
Thank You Carlton cause you know his
name you didn't even have to guess it at
all you would
that guy must never want to leave his
house cuz everywhere he goes he's
Carlton
I know maybe he does any [ __ ] loves it
cuz he never did anything else he's a
[ __ ] dance monkey it's like here I
have five that's what happens to people
that like their death their one thing
and then the charcoal dude yeah
dessert will have anything he's done a
couple other things all I see is Oracle
in every single movie he did some shitty
sci-fi oh by the way monkey and this
turn was not a racial term monkey is
just the saying that you say when you
ask somebody Oh cuz Carlton's black yeah
I keep me gonna call this black Oh
dance monkey I serious I'm right because
people might misinterpret that yeah
that's what you say for everybody
oh yeah yeah god I hate that we have to
clarify that detail you know what he's
so [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] because when people
tell us to go uh hey do something funny
hey do that one thing that you always do
do the accent or whatever and it that's
literally dance monkey dance yeah yeah
yeah but this Carlton knows so he was a
suspect and in a cold case which is kind
of ironic here cuz he was the one that
jumped out of a freezer two attacks and
cafe workers that's funny
got a freezer he was his [ __ ]
chilling in there like I'm gonna get
these mother [ __ ] funny well cuz
she's also saying he was part of us who
a cold case meaning like it was kind of
like they don't know who did that hurt
no more leads yeah I Spit killer that's
what he is
wait what why did he want attack him was
he trying to run so this is kind of like
a head scratcher here because they don't
know how he even ended up in New York
this happened in Manhattan he he's
jumped out of a walk-in freezer he had a
knife and he was shouting away Satan oh
[ __ ] yeah and [ __ ] you okay right now
his fate or he was facing murder charges
in the 1988 shooting of two men in
Boston
damn what if he went to Hell's Kitchen
thinking that like you know
so you went to New York so clean up
Hell's Kitchen yeah that's too bad
nice man comma right here that [ __ ] was
dope that connection was wild yeah I
know New York she died of a fatal heart
attack after he jumped out of it my me
killed himself
pretty much with it ya heart attack dude
this is a [ __ ] comedy like you can't
write this [ __ ] baby he was close to
death already so he could start to see
into the beyond and he could see the
[ __ ] demons like in there in their
space he was fighting the Grim Reaper
cuz death was coming why not
and Grim Reaper is a sous-chef in the
middle of Manhattan that's why I always
wonder our crazy people crazy when
they're yelling at [ __ ] no I think
they're on a different dimension and
they can actually talk to [ __ ] I say why
not I would believe that if we get a
room of this of crazy people and they're
talking to the same spec so if I if we
get like 30 crazy people right and
they're just like well this guy won't
shut the [ __ ] up and they're pointing in
nothing and they'll all know what that
person is and the same name that's
chilling that's usually not the case
those usually they're all have an own
conversation yeah you know what it is
it's just uncontrolled neuroticism it's
just going outwards not left in here
give it that's less fun I know I like
the spirit one let's go back to the
spirit one so here's my theory is that
crazy people and babies they talk in the
same realm so then when they you know
[ __ ] talk to themselves and whatever
they're all communicating on so my yeah
yeah I've also seen some of the most
aggressive but courteous and polite
homeless people that are like so there's
a back when we just live in downtown
there's like this little patch of dirt
that we walked our dogs ooh and there's
this guy like [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you and he look like he was just
ready to throw down with anybody get
headphones on and a sleeping bag and he
would like [ __ ] you [ __ ] the [ __ ]
agent he puts the sleeping bag down he
was gonna go inside he crawls inside
[ __ ] you [ __ ] and then the security
guard comes no sir you can't lay here he
goes
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you me get out it still
rolls up his sleeping bag as if like
there's a side of him that's like I'm so
sorry sir
and he rolls it how many walks down the
street stop oh my damn this guy is like
to please the balls trash butts in the
garbage can there's nobody was gonna
swing on him because of how aggressive
you wouldn't let the security guards
just chill in like yep I was gonna sweep
my [ __ ] it was a fight about to break
out but he was just so polite he just
rolled it up and [ __ ] move out this
side I start feeling worse for homeless
people depending on the weather
oh I know the hotter it is the more I
give the colder it is the more I give if
it's a sunny day I'm like [ __ ] you
whenever it's raining and I'm like yeah
it's raining I always like the back of
my head I'm like almost yeah but what if
they like it yes finally I get to take a
shower maybe that's that's probably true
I highly doubt that's the case yeah and
the next day you see like shiny clean
homeless people there's just a lot of
like interesting situations that like I
said Pasadena has a lot of homeless
people that people don't even know like
there's just a lot there same guy every
time I come out the gym saying hey sir
good just a changeable sandwich I'm like
hey what if I get you a semi goes I
don't want sandwich okay that's like
every time somebody's like it's like oh
I want a white Christmas this year it's
like think of all the homeless people
like who like her freezing to death
please let there be a lot of rain in LA
please Christmas this year and has lived
in LA as welcome down in the 70s it did
where was a white Christmas it was in
the 70 it snowed on accident hailed like
a [ __ ] here like five years ago
that was crazy
I think we were here and then it started
hitting our cars yeah yeah yeah no was
that our one we had we didn't have a
office yet we were living at 6:09 I
remember opening the door in there
good news and there was hella hell
outside yeah yeah yeah but these were
huge at that time that's crazy man where
there's like crazy so nice I don't know
I think wait what's this article about
because I keep thinking about spirits
you trying to figure it out see the
whole time without us I'm so [ __ ]
focused on spirits about the man who
freezer crazy guy in case Killa who died
cold case exactly that guy
damn what kind of restaurant was it it
was that question was coming out it was
a popular Manhattan eatery we're hungry
okay I know I mean - on the Upper West
Side
Sarabeth how did he get in the freezer
that's the crazies yeah have you been in
a in an environment of restaurant
environment like sometimes you don't
even see people like you just assume
everyone works there already so busy
well that and you don't you don't know
that all the shifts and [ __ ] cuz you're
like if you know time they're a hundred
percent of the time you don't know
that's true and then there's delivery
guys yeah I come in bring the produce
yeah they just walk straight into the
fridge and drop it off all that stuff
it's always different people can see why
it happened best sub Charlie look crazy
like he looks like a regular cat you
know except you stare as knows the whole
time you know what though if you do have
anger problems though the freezer can
chill you out like literally it really
about this waiter why he's staring at
his nose like how's he gonna work today
I don't know if you have a family I'm
not sure that's them yeah you probably
ate them I like hanging out him big
refrigerators whenever you've been in a
bit like a produce like Costco yeah but
like no cuz I used to work at a
restaurant and the big refrigerators
like the walk-in I get it that that's
it's like on a hot day - it chills you
out immediately I get to creeped out
like I walked into the
they have like Casey's parents
restaurant are you gonna lock in there
huh I walk in and I'm just like I have
to have one arm outside like I'm just so
good even though there's a handle inside
do you think it's gonna close forever
yeah I don't know I mean there is a
handle for me though Oh get out but
still don't you like the smell of the
refrigerator it's not you I [ __ ] love
it I love that restore I like opening
the freezer section and I [ __ ] freon
dude I yeah yeah oh baby there's
something so graceful ii-i've been
killing my brain cells I love this mall
gasoline to sharpies I'd love this non
sharply yeah like rubbery glue talk
about rubber cement yes the lacquers
like if you're working with wood and
it's like this clear topical for the
wood he loves who me no I do
I like that refrigerators like Costco
like walking into and just chillin out
laughs no when you how about going to
the refrigerator section of like a Home
Depot and opening they're free opening
the refrigerator and [ __ ] smelling
inside of it dude
Home Depot that's bad cuz it's not even
cold or anything else nice smells bonds
smells weird all appliances section yeah
yeah when you're in the refrigerator
section dude cuz it just smells like no
it smells like fresh appliance it smells
bad oh yeah fresh appliance yeah only
fresh appliances not I do like is max I
need you to get the [ __ ] out of this
room right how are you are you talking
about bro just come with me there's a
Home Depot really close to here gonna do
another J kiddies I'm like hey Steve
we're gonna see a vlog on your channel
of you guys going you know what it's
[ __ ] Bob well we just have my room
lined up with fridges open you will love
it
[Music]